i think the biggest thing for me was
learning to separate the broken self
feeling
and when you realize that like we are
never broken like
that broken things happen to us like
things will injure our heart you know
but it's not that our heart is
bad it's that it got injured it's not
that you know our spirit is bad it's
just that it's been
hurt and i called it ed eating disorder
and i would just be like
i don't deserve to feel that way like
i'm not gonna let you tell me
that i you know and i still everyone so
i start to feel it kind of come back i'm
just like
i've done without you for a really long
time i don't need you in my life and i'm
not gonna let you
make me feel like that about my body and
even though sometimes that's hard to say
because i'm like but right now i do feel
like that about my body and it's like
but i'm not gonna let you tell me
i don't want you in my life yeah that's
super powerful
to separate it from you i've never heard
it described like that that's that's so
smart
um because it's really the mind is so
powerful
the mind created it the mind can get rid
of it exactly and
you at your core are whole and perfect
and
pure and anything else is just the
reason why it doesn't feel good is
because it's not you
yeah mm-hmm yes and i remember like i
had a dream one night where
it i it was like creepiest dream i've
ever had and it was my eating disorder
was this
scary woman who was controlling
everything i did
and i was the only person that could see
her and i was at a party with
a bunch of people in the room and she
just followed me and
every time i'd do anything she would
hand me a piece of paper
and i'd have to sign a contract with her
and she'd take it like it's like she
knew everything i was doing
and controlling it and it was the
creepiest dream and i remember waking up
just being like
that's my life i don't want that anymore
i don't want to be controlled by this
thing
it's not me wow wow was that
i mean did that stuff start to peek in i
mean because
you know i you you were much younger so
you talked about dancing in college
right so you would have been
barely 20. um i mean then you go on
stage and now you're like
now you're on stage all the time and it
does it desensitize you even more
to those thought patterns or does it
make it come
up even more where you have to like
practice
the self you know self love is so
overused but
practice that sort of disassociation
with the thoughts
and realize that they're not gonna to
not want them to be
a part of your part of your life um or
you know which side of it does it fall
for you um
you know i honestly think it hasn't
changed it i feel like
success or notoriety or any of that
stuff it doesn't actually
change who you are it just like
amplifies whatever you
are and so i feel like the same
triggers the same insecurities that you
know the same things i'm confident about
since becoming like more successful in
life they've
been having more money or whatever you
want to say they've only all gotten
bigger and i just have to kind of keep
working on all the same things um
you know and i continuously get better
at them but that's one of them is it
will come back and when it comes back it
um and it when i say come back i've
never i haven't relapsed
you know since like my first relapse you
know
in recovery but the feelings will come
back
and i have to nip it in the bud before
it
because i know what it could do to me
and so um and it's funny even with my
friends like you said everybody's got
some sort of a
relationship with food and i'll talk to
my friends who
um they never had eating disorders you
know or clinically
described eating disorders but yet we'll
talk about the relationship with food
and how
it's hard sometimes to be like is this
me being
healthy and aware that maybe i do need
to take a little better charge of my
my body and my diet or is this my mind
being unhealthy and
lying to me and being mean and it's like
this constant battle to like evaluate
and for me it just comes from what's the
source
like what's the actual source of why i
feel this way
yeah and you know where is it coming
from and that can help me evaluate like
why is it valid for me to like think i
need to do a little better
you know because there's value in that
or is it me beating myself up because i
have
low self-worth because i don't think i'm
enough you know
um anyway so it's a constant little
battle but i just
um i've gotten really good at
recognizing when it starts to come back